i've got good news and i've got bad news
the good news is that joe biden is
finally ending the covid restrictions
the bad news is he's only ending them
for illegal aliens who are trying to
break into our country
law-abiding american citizens still need
to muzzle up at least on public
transportation where the cdc has
reportedly decided to extend the federal
mass mandate
for just two more weeks
just two two more weeks where have i
heard that one before
at the same time joe biden is officially
ending the title 42 public health
authority first invoked by president
trump that allowed immigration officials
to turn away illegal aliens and send
them back to their native countries
relatively quickly compared to the rest
of our system
so
biden is apparently worried that
americans might spread the new
sub-variance of the variant of the virus
that even in its most virulent form
never posed much of a threat
at all to the vast majority of americans
but he's not worried that millions of
unvetted foreigners from countries with
much lower public health standards than
we have we'll spread the same virus to
each other and to us great news for
people who want to take advantage of our
country
bad news for our country's own citizens
in other words
more of the same i'm michael knowles
it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from moose chuckle
who says i grew up poor when i turned 18
i moved off worked my derriere off to go
to college that's not the word he used i
just cleaned it up a little bit and i
made a life for myself
now i'm glad that my kids will have the
same chance that i did that is to grow
up poor that's true that's really
looking at the bright side of things
every storm cloud has a silver lining as
we seem stuck like it's groundhog day
two weeks after two weeks after two
years later here we are again
nothing changing here to help me make
sense of this because you know we do not
merely want to
be pyromaniacs in a field of strong men
we want to hear out what the other side
has to say and hear the best arguments
for what what seems to us to be
absolutely absurd kind of policy so
we're very happy to be joined by jen
perlman who is an attorney an activist a
former congressional candidate in
florida's 23rd congressional district
and right now the force behind the
generational change podcast and i love
me a good pun jen thank you for coming
on the show
thank you for having me so
jen this is our first time meeting we
haven't really spoken before
i don't know where you stand on this
issue frankly i don't know where the
majority of democrats stand on this
issue but it seems to me
two years later two years
now more than two years after two weeks
to slow the spread
isn't the kovid stuff over can't we move
on and take the mask off and go back in
public and just live live our lives
well i have um you're not gonna get
you're not gonna get that much of an
argument from me i'm i'm pretty
vehemently opposed to mandates in
general um
i think that
the policies for kovid from the
beginning have been based on two things
fear and profit and neither of those
things are reason and that's generally
how i like to go about policy making is
through reason
and uh that's not how it's ever been
handled so i i totally agree with you do
you think that that view because i i've
heard other left wingers say this though
it seems to be a maybe a minority view
on the democrat side just knowing the
party do you think that the majority of
democrats are with biden on this and
keep locking down and keep wearing masks
or do you think they're ready to move on
uh okay so when you say the majority of
democrats okay that's a very interesting
thing because technically i'm one i'm
registered as one i lived in i live in a
closed primary state so i have very i
have no option for myself but i don't
agree with them i don't support their
policy i don't like joe and i don't
think the majority of people do
so when you say democrats like yeah
there's going to be certain
establishment right you know blue or die
people that are just going to say yes to
whatever he said but i don't think most
people support him i think his poll
numbers show that
i think you're right about that i mean
you know the the poll numbers are in the
doldrums and it's not just true of biden
it's true for the entire administration
kamala's down at 35 or something right
now buddha judge has been there around
the whole time he was the next one they
kind of wanted to make happen so then
good luck good luck yeah i agree with
you i don't think he's going anywhere so
then then what does that mean for the
party because i don't think that your
anti-establishment anti-biden
perspective is particularly fringe in
the democratic party if you look policy
after policy right now it would seem to
me that the majority or at least a huge
number of democrats really don't like
what biden is doing so so what what does
that mean for 2022 and 2024
oh i think it's very easy we're going to
get the dems are going to get their
asses handed to them this year and
i am actually and i've been saying this
for a very long time i truly believe
your next president is going to either
be donald trump or ron desantis and and
the democrats are the only people that
don't seem to know this actually in
florida they're extremely delusional in
florida they're actually running a race
against desantis this year for governor
that they have zero chance of winning
and in my mind he's not even running
that he already won that he's running
for president already so the democrats
at least in florida are very behind the
eight ball i think they're living in a
fantasy land and again i'm referring to
the people on the inside the the
establishment democrats not just
everybody who's registered as a democrat
so is your issue with the party that uh
they they're not enough like desantis
you know we've got to go they've got to
go much further to the right or are you
hitting them from the left
oh i'm left of them for sure i'm left of
them for sure uh but my issue with all
of it is the corruption
um if
like i would support let me tell you i
will support and i and i will do and i
am doing that actually right now in
north carolina i will support a
non-corporate republican over a
corporate democrat
so for me it comes down to who do you
work for and who pays your salary and
the way i see it is they they're
supposed to work for us those are our
employees they're extremely
insubordinate
um and as a result we can't get policy
that the majority of people want so i
don't support anybody who's a corporate
[ __ ] and that goes for both sides of
the aisle i remember a lot of my friends
in la some of whom were pretty prominent
left wingers actually before 2016 they
said if the democrats nominate hillary
she's going to lose i won't vote for her
my friends won't vote for her because
she's this absolute corporate
establishment shill and
she won't offer us a choice she want you
know it'll be a an echo rather than a
choice to parrot the language of the
right 50 years ago so
what would your advice be right now
you're in the room you've got all those
crooked democrat establishment types
there who are just trying to run the
same old playbook what would you tell
them to do to have a chance against a
trump against a desantis against whoever
the nominee is going to be
right now the movement is populism okay
it's populism on the left it's populism
on the right and i said this in 16. i
said to people i said if you don't
support bernie you're getting trump
that's it hillary has no chance of
winning um i knew that then i i
understand it because she's horrible uh
there's nothing that would have made me
vote for her and so you know they are
not responding to what people want and
particularly what labor needs
if you're not see labor is the unifying
force amongst us if you go to a labor
rally for example you're going to meet
reds and blues there and they're not
going to be sitting there and arguing
about wedge issues they're going to be
sitting there and be fighting for a
living wage if they're where they work
and those are things that unify all of
us the the democrats need to get behind
um
economic policy that will help people
and stop worrying about wedge issues
that are just there to make them look
like they have some sort of like moral
high ground they're extremely
sanctimonious they don't offer any real
substance of strategy or anything that
will help regular people get themselves
out of the mess that we're in right now
you know you're focusing on something
that's so insightful which is look i'm a
culture warrior i think some of the
cultural issues are important especially
now in education i think they drive
voters but i think you're right on this
labor point historically speaking the
party that can speak to american workers
and can talk that language and offer
them something very often does well
because you get red and you get blue and
which the party of pittsburgh tends to
do a little bit better than the party of
paris and right now democrats have made
themselves the party of paris i've got
to let you go i'm up against a break jen
where can people find you
i am at generational change on youtube
spotify and on itunes and our website is
generationalchange.com that's
generational with a j
and i'm at
jfl23 on twitter i love that but next
time you come back by that time i hope i
will have a cool pun for my podcast
title we'll need a little bit of time to
work on it maybe you can offer some
suggestions if i come up with something
good i'll give it to you i don't even
see you
so uh yeah but if i think of something
really good i'll offer it to you please
do email it over to me i appreciate it
jen jen perlman thank you so much for
coming on
it's very important folks when you are
trying to
change your country you need to vote for
the right candidates and it's very
important when you're trying to change
and improve your company that you hire
the right candidates is what which is
why you need ziprecruiter right now go
to ziprecruiter.com
knowles if you need to add more
employees to your team there is
ziprecruiter their matching technology
helps you find the right people for your
roles fast it's not just throwing
spaghetti at the wall and then you hope
something sticks ziprecruiter which you
can try for free at zipruder.com knowles
has such effective technology that four
out of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day they will go out they will
help you identify those top candidates
they will invite them to apply you know
time is money and you know the most
important investment you're going to
make is in your employees personnel is
policy as they say find the right
employees for your workplace with
ziprecruiter you can try it for free at
this exclusive web address that is
ziprecruiter.com
knowles k-w-l-e-s that is again zip
recruiter.com
zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
you know i have to tell you i expected
more support for joe biden's policies
from jen from a democrat candidate but
when when you look at the poll numbers
maybe i shouldn't have actually because
as she said she said look i'm not a
republican i don't support republicans
but by a lot of democrats don't support
what biden is doing right now the poll
numbers reflect that i think the white
house knows it frankly i think that's
why they're pushing the kovitz stuff
is because i think they know when
they're looking at how little support
they have among even democrats when you
look at something like the florida law
that the white house went all in
opposing the florida education law and
yet the majority of democrats support
the florida education law that that is
being dishonestly called the don't say
gay bill so if you look at the the
electoral map if you look at the voters
and likely voters democrats are getting
crushed right now so it would seem to me
their only chance to do even somewhat
well in november
is to rig the election
is to send out all those widespread
mail-in ballots
that are totally open to abuse
is to extend election day to election
month is to do all the sorts of stuff
they did in 2020 that years ago even
barack obama admitted was extremely
crooked and which in some cases is
prohibited by state laws and state
constitutions
i think that's what they're going for i
also think that there is a second
issue here behind the the mask on public
transportation
i and i haven't heard anyone talking
about this
i think that biden is afraid that if he
lifts the mask mandates on public
transportation then the return to
airlines the return to
to travel is going to be so great that
it's going to drive oil prices up even
higher
this makes perfect sense to me you're
already seeing people going back to
travel but there are still impediments
to it it's still very uncomfortable a
lot of people still say i'm not going to
wear the mask well right now we're in an
all-time high in terms of
gas prices certainly at the pump oil
prices are going through the roof
i think part of the reason that they're
forcing people to keep wearing these
dumb masks is just to keep oil prices
somewhat down compared to where they
could be
it's a little bit cynical but i don't
think there's any depth of cynicism to
which the biden administration will not
sink that from the very beginning they
have used covid as an excuse to get the
political outcomes that they want that
are sometimes even unrelated to to covet
dr fauci has admitted this dr fauci
who i you know i hate to say i told you
so but i told you he was coming back he
went into witness protection for a few
weeks but he's coming back he was just
on msnbc he was discussing the lockdowns
in china the very heavy lockdowns in
china and he said well in a way it sort
of kind of makes sense because
you you just use lockdowns to create
incentives to get people to do what you
want them to do
china has has a number of problems two
of which are
that their complete
lockdown
which was their approach a strictest
lockdown that you'd never be able to
implement
in the united states
although that prevents the spread of
infection and remember early on
they were saying and i think accurately
that they were doing better than almost
anybody else but lockdown has its
consequences you use lockdowns
to get people vaccinated so that when
you open up
you won't have a surge
of infections because you're dealing
with an immunologically naive population
to the virus because they've not really
been exposed because of the lockdown
you so many things that dr fauci says
here are so revealing one he changes his
argument for lockdowns
remember the original argument for
lockdowns was you need to flatten the
curve slow the spread the reason for
lockdowns is so that you don't overwhelm
the hospital system you're still going
to get the same number of people
infected but if you spread it out you
won't go over the capacity of the
hospital system so people won't
needlessly die that was the argument
they never made the argument yeah we're
going to lock down so that we can force
you all to take this experimental shot
they never made that argument because if
they made that argument people would
have said two words to them the words
aren't happy birthday and they would
have ignored the lockdowns so they said
no it's about flattening the curve and
not overwhelming the hospital system now
that she completely changes his argument
no it's about it's actually about
getting people to take the shot
furthermore when he says that america is
not going to engage in a chinese-style
lockdown
he's saying it
with regret he's he's saying that that
kind of a lockdown could never work in
america
but it the chinese were doing much
better than we were
much better much better what they're
doing is good if only we could do that
but we have this damn democracy thing we
have this stupid constitutional system
that prevents us from doing that
so he says yeah don't worry we're not
going to go where china's going
if only we could would that it were so
simple and furthermore i don't believe
him that we can't go where china's going
dr fauci said at the beginning of all
the kovid nonsense he said you're not
going to see lockdowns they when they're
not going to lock down new york or los
angeles i can't even imagine them doing
that and then what do they do they do
that for a lot more than two weeks
that's for sure
they're probably going to do it again
so nothing he says here is true
or honest all of it is deceptive and you
can't even believe what he's saying now
because he's contradicting what he
previously had said
the only the only thing i believe out of
fouchy from that whole comment
is that he views
lockdowns and public health measures in
general
as
major incentives
to to for to get people to do whatever
sort of political policy he wants them
to engage in that's what it's about and
sometimes it's a little more
heavy-handed than at other times
right now if you if you're flying
through dallas love field one of the
airports in dallas
you might encounter ornery
tsa agents you might encounter people
yelling at you to put your mask on
behind the counters
and you might encounter seven foot tall
robots who threaten to call the police
if you don't wear your mask properly
this is not the plot of some kind of
arnold schwarzenegger movie this is not
some dystopian crazy fantasy coming out
of my tinfoil hat fever dreams this is
being reported right now in fortune
magazine dallas airport uses robocops to
enforce mask policy listen to
the nicest
promotional
best marketing that these robots have
welcome to dallas love field airport
all ubers
lifts
taxis and rental car shuttles are
located on the lower level
to access the lower level please use an
escalator or elevator proceed downstairs
the first thing that strikes me about
these robots is um
i don't think we're gonna see mrs robot
anytime soon
i don't know not to be stereotypical or
anything i don't think the robots wear
shoes but if they did i think those sh
they would be a little
how do you say a little light in the
loafers uh just because well just
there's just something about the voice
sounds sort of very nice and calm
but they're not merely offering people
directions oh here's how you get to the
gate oh there's a delay oh this the the
robots that are being tested out here
might issue a verbal warning this is a
quote according to fortune magazine
uh they they are looking through their
cameras to determine whether a passenger
is wearing a face mask which is still
mandated they might issue a verbal
warning if you're not which could
escalate in volume and severity if the
infraction is not corrected and the
system can also call on-site security or
the police if necessary
are
are we living in china
i know these days especially when we
look at it foreign policy it's very
fashionable to say we're here in the
land of the free thank goodness we're in
the land of the free
not like those autocratic regimes around
the world like russia or certainly not
like china
that that's good
are because our police enforcement
robots speak english
our constant surveillance everywhere and
our requirement to muzzle ourselves
wherever we go
it's
it sounds a little nicer and i don't
know it's very difficult to see the
difference between the united states and
china these days increasingly it's
difficult i guess the only difference i
can point out right now
is that
our movies are a little bit gayer
i think that's the big difference at
this point america in 2022 biden's
america all the authoritarianism of
china but with movies that have a little
bit more eccentric sex stuff
because that is the chinese regime right
now is clamping down
on some of the more
woke and eccentric and radical sexual
ideologies
that the the united states has been
producing and exporting around the world
world so you've got
right now hollywood complaining about
for instance the don't say gay bill in
florida meaning the parental rights and
education bill which says you can't
trans the five-year-olds hollywood is
saying this is horrible we're going to
donate so much money against it disney
staging walkouts disney is saying that
they're going to fight this legislation
in florida around the country
and then xi jinping calls them up
and says hello mr disney uh your movie
specifically the the new harry potter
movie
has six seconds of an allusion to a gay
relationship take it out or you're you
don't have access to our market
and what does hollywood do do you think
they make a courageous and principled
stand for the rights of lgbt
no of course not they take the six
seconds out
because
no matter how woke they are
cash is king for these people
and they're
whether they're red whether they're blue
their real ideology is green and so they
take the money from the chinese
communists and what you're seeing is
exactly what we're seeing at the border
exactly what we're seeing on biden's
coveted policy what you're seeing is
greater care and consideration being
given to foreign nationals
than to american citizens by our own
elites by the ruling class whether it's
in the government or in corporate
america
they're
they have no problem with
authoritarianism uh whatsoever
it's just that in america they're going
to make the movies a little bit more gay
if that if that's really all that
separates us from china that's really
sad
frankly if if china is saying hey none
of this transgender stuff you don't
we're with florida you don't get to
trans the kids in your movies then
you're going to be in this really
bizarre scenario where where we here in
america are going to have to go find the
chinese cut of these movies to show our
kids that's not the kind of situation
you want your country to be in it's not
healthy when you want to feel healthy
though i'd recommend you check out
superbeats right now go to
superbeats.com
knowles this is the new way to start
your day and you're going to love it
super beets heart chews they are a tasty
treat that gives you the energy you need
and that is good for you no more
afternoon coffees oh should i have my
sixth cup of coffee today none of that
no more al what about my tenth energy
drink no maybe i'll just throw a little
candy in for a quick pick-me-up no you
just add two delicious plant-based super
beets art juice to your morning routine
to promote heart-healthy energy for your
day without that caffeine crash super
beets heart chews unique clinically
researched grape seed extract promotes
heart-healthy energy and normal blood
pressure as part of a healthy lifestyle
the grape seed extract used in super
beets heart shoes has been clinically
shown to be twice as effective at
supporting normal blood pressure as a
healthy lifestyle alone do more for your
heart treat yourself with super beats
heart shoes
right now only for our listeners get up
to 45
off four or five that's a huge number
plus free shipping at superbeats.com
knowles this is their best offer
available anywhere we really appreciate
superbeats for supporting the show and
for being a great product so you should
go check it out too superbeats.com
knowles get up to 45 off
superbeats.com these statements and
products have not been evaluated by the
food and drug administration these
products are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease or
condition
i don't want to play as many clips from
the view as i do i don't look i don't
want to i don't think the view matters
that much i don't think the view really
shapes political discourse i don't think
it's the cause of political discourse
but i do think it's a symptom of it the
reason that i play clips of joy behar
saying stupid things or whoopi goldberg
saying stupid things
is is not because i think they're
influencing a whole lot of people maybe
some
housewives in
blue states maybe i don't know
but
it's because they are perfectly
embodying the degradation of american
political discourse
just the other day they were talking
about this issue of sexual ideology and
lgbt and the terrible awful florida law
that says you can't lop off the genitals
of little kids and you can't talk about
transgenderism in a kindergarten
classroom
actually you know the florida law
doesn't even say that you can't actually
trans the kids it just says you can't
talk about trancing the kids in certain
classrooms vivek ramaswamy has been
calling it the wait till eight bill
nine years old you can try to
transgender them but eight it's too far
but but the view and the the left in
general they're very upset about this
take a listen to the the great
sophistication with which they're
discussing the issue of sexual ethics
who decided
that a traditional marriage is a man and
a woman who came up with this plan well
everything that exists in nature
right people say it's unnatural but
isn't everything that exists
by definition it is natural but is
homosexuality even mentioned in the
bible i don't think it is i believe it
is
i like the other hosts i said no i no
enjoy it
no it is i mean it's definitely
mentioned i know that joy behar has
never cracked the spine of a bible in
her entire life but no it's mentioned
and there's you know there's actually a
kind of long history of debating sexual
ethics and and morality
but but what it boils down to what
they're actually expressing is this view
that all that is
all that morality comes down to is if it
feels good do it i remember having the
thought that i don't know that woman's
name the guest on the show who said if
if it if it happens in nature it's
natural come on right it's cool so we
should all do it i remember having that
thought when i was seven years old i
remember thinking what do you mean how's
there a difference between natural and
artificial
in food or in anything else
when everything's got to come from
nature originally even if we make it a
laboratory it's from nature because
we're natural you know man you know
right that's that's the kind of idea
that a first or second grader has and
then hopefully they move past that to a
deeper level of discourse
but her argument is that we need to
sanction and even encourage
all manner of sexual behavior or i guess
any other kind of behavior if anyone has
a natural impulse to do it because it's
natural and therefore good
this gets to something we were talking
to last night talking about last night
on the backstage show and it was a point
that drew kept driving home which is
we have a right to norms
we have a right to standards
this was the thesis of my book
speechless
which the people who haven't read my
book think it's a book about how
censorship is terrible and free speech
is good and the left is
bad and the right is good and the book
is actually a little more nuanced than
that and it says that this we're
actually looking at this issue in
entirely the wrong way and drew
articulated it pretty well last night he
said we have a right to norms and
standards someone can be born with
five five fingers total two and a half
on each hand and half a brain and
missing a leg and you could say that's
natural right it happens in nature but
it's
it's a product of nature having
imperfections and we all have
imperfections and we all have things
that are a little weird about us and
that are a little bit off because this
is a fallen world
that doesn't mean that there are no
standards it doesn't mean that people
aren't supposed to have 10 fingers and
10 toes and sometimes people don't quite
hit those standards
doesn't mean that society has to
completely throw out all
norms and all understanding of normative
behavior we have a right to that
it doesn't mean that we're going to be
really mean to everybody and throw
gay guys in prison or
attach electrodes to people like the
libs imagine that mike pence does or
something but we are allowed to have
norms
we are allowed to say men and women are
supposed to go together and they're
complementary and that's at the center
of human society because that's how we
propagate the species and because men
and women actually have something to
offer to one another not just physically
but spiritually and emotionally and all
sorts of things and that's that's good
and that's that's what it
i think we're still allowed to say that
with the democrats who are upset about
the florida law
are arguing is that we don't have a
right to say that and it's and it's an
area where the conservatives don't
really have an answer to it
because what the conservatives have said
what the democrats have said is the
florida law is about not saying gay and
of course
the word gay doesn't appear anywhere in
the florida law so then the republicans
are coming in and they're saying well
you might as well call it the don't say
straight bill we just want sex
completely out of the elementary school
classrooms
and it's mostly right but it's a little
bit wrong too because
if you're reading a storybook if you're
reading a fairy tale to to
five-year-olds or six-year-olds in story
time class
that might involve a marriage
i think that's fine i don't think that's
awful terrible indoctrination for for a
story that's read in kindergarten to be
about a family
but i do think it would be wrong for the
story reading kindergarten to be about a
throuple living in brooklyn
i think husband and wife with two little
cute kids and a dog in the yard i think
you're allowed to you should be allowed
to read that story
and i think uh transgender sally
marrying pansexual
jupiter and and living in a co-op in in
crown heights i don't i don't think you
should read that to kindergarteners i
think
i think we're allowed to have norms and
to say this behavior is actually normal
behavior and ought to be encouraged and
it doesn't mean that we're going to
ostracize and be really mean to people
who don't
quite fit that mold who don't who don't
want to do that who don't want to live
in that way but we do have a right
to our standards and norms which are
collapsing all around the world right
now
that slippery slope that the
conservatives were warning about for
decades that the libs always made fun of
us for warning about well we're almost
at the bottom of it we're about as far
down as you can go there's a horrifying
story just came out of canada
out of america's hat here which is
important because canada is a little
further down the line on some of these
crazy social policies but we very likely
will end up where they are
the headline is woman with chemical
sensitivities chose medically assisted
death after failed bid to get better
housing
this is a woman she's 51 years old in
ontario she says that she has severe
sensitivities to chemicals and she chose
assisted suicide to kill herself because
she was living in salvation army housing
and she she couldn't get
a an apartment where she wasn't smelling
cigarette smoke or where she wasn't
smelling other cleaning materials
and it was it was manageable before
kovid but then when the government
locked her up at home during covid she
she couldn't get out and
what she complained about too was that
during covid people were smoking more
people were cleaning more so this these
chemicals were floating through the air
she was hypersensitive to it and so she
chose to kill herself a lot of people
are focusing on how awful it was that
she couldn't find better housing because
she had this medical condition it's
worth pointing out this medical
condition probably doesn't exist this
idea of a hypersensitivity to the smell
of chemicals there is no scientific
evidence that there's any such thing
it's not really a firm medical diagnosis
there's a similar
pseudo-medical condition called
electromagnetic hypersensitivity it's
actually the central plot point for the
first few seasons of
of better coleslaw the spinoff of
breaking bad it's not if not the central
plot point it's a very major plot point
to it that one of the characters thinks
that he has a hypersensitivity to
electricity but he doesn't really it's
it's a it's really a mental condition
and so i suspect i don't
we don't know there's no real scientific
conclusion on this but i suspect what
happened here is a woman
with
some mental problems
was driven mad matter by coveted
and doctors allowed an otherwise healthy
51 year old woman to kill herself the
problem here is not the cruel society
that didn't get her a better apartment
the problem here is assisted suicide
which should not be permitted
anywhere at any time
because
when it is permitted and this is the
perfect example of the slippery slope i
think the act is wrong in and of itself
and it's not should not be permitted and
if people are have the worst most
terrible conditions and a lot of pain
you can give them pain medication you
can give them palliative care but you
should not be allowed to kill yourself
it's disordered and it's intrinsically
wrong but the slippery slope is a big
problem too the minute they legalized
these things especially in europe and
belgium and the netherlands all of a
sudden it wasn't just the most
terminally ill who have days to live all
of a sudden then it was people who have
emotional problems it was people who
actually changed their mind but they
were killed anyway it was kids some kids
now teenagers are allowed to kill
themselves like this this is the sign of
a truly sick society and unlike
electromagnetic sensitivity or chemical
sensitivity this sickness is real and we
can measure it and it's getting worse if
there's one thing we can be sure of
it's that disney is screwing up they're
screwing up our kids and they're
screwing up their own company by the way
which is why the daily wire is investing
100 million dollars into creating a
platform for kids
for kids just to entertain them to give
them our basic values basic norms but
we're not putting political message
first okay we're putting entertainment
first and we've hired the veggie tales
writers to help create our first two
children shows chill a time about a
family of homeschooled chinchillas and
doodles with noodles that centers on a
man and his puppet giving drawing
lessons i could probably use them giving
my painting abilities in order to change
the culture you got to make the culture
and daily wire is making the culture
thing is we need your help today you can
head to dailywire.com subscribe use code
build the future for 45 off your
membership the offer ends today we've
never offered something like this 45 off
but we need it we need your support more
than ever we're so appreciative for your
support so far it's allowed us
to do what we've done and break the mold
and really really grow we need your
support head on over subscribe right now
we'll be right back with a lot more
how do we make the country less radical
less crazy and more conservative
we've had lots of ideas in recent
decades and they haven't really worked
sometimes you'll hear conservatives talk
about our big victories oh we've had big
victories in the with the judges and the
courts and on policy have we because now
we're transing the kids so it seems like
we've lost every single battle it seems
like marriage has been completely
redefined and the family has been
cracked i i hope not irreparably but
possibly
our foreign policy is in complete
disarray our economy is in the doldrums
gas is through the roof inflation is at
all time highs we've got regularly
political activists burning down the
country crime spiking everywhere and now
we can't even say that boys are girls or
boys aren't girls rather
unless you're a biologist and even then
you're not allowed to say the supreme
court nominee can't say what a woman is
she was picked because she's a woman and
she can't even say that she's a woman so
no i don't think we've won i think we've
lost i think we've lost everything
so whatever the old playbook was which
is be quiet on the social issues and
uh placate whatever handful of
squishy corporate billionaires and and
do whatever they want us to do and just
cut taxes that's not working
so we gotta think outside the box how
are we gonna make the country more
conservative charlie kirk just offered
an idea his idea is
stop building
tall buildings and build
flatter buildings
we have a huge housing crisis in our
country the likes of which we have not
seen in a long period of time but i
believe that we need to build
horizontally not vertically it's one of
my speeches developers don't like it
when i say this but it's true the higher
the building the more liberal the voter
it just is so and if if you are the
closer to the ground you are the more
conservative you are we should we should
encourage people to spread horizontally
and not vertically look at denver the
higher the high rises has denver become
less free or more free it's become a
dystopian nightmare you guys know that
now you might say charlie that's a
correlation on the causation think about
it if you're on the 32nd floor renting
not owning if you're not in the weeds
and in the yard and understanding what
it takes to grow food and to maintain
the land are you gonna be more or less
likely to actually be a conservative the
higher the building every single study
shows they become more liberal over time
it's happening in phoenix happened in
denver happened atlanta happened in
dallas happened in chicago have
everywhere and yet few people actually
say that out loud whatever
all the libs are making fun of charlie
and some of the really fancy fashionable
conservatives they're all making fun of
charlie you idiot
oh here he goes here goes crazy charlie
kirk saying what there's a problem with
skyscrapers or architecture and that's
what's making the country more liberal
uh yeah in part
yeah he's totally right he's totally
right this is not only true i saw this
split because the left-wing organization
media matters tweeted it out and i
thought oh good job media matters i'm
glad that you are making this go viral
because not only is what charlie said
obviously true but it's one of the most
insightful things i've ever heard him
say
and this is something that conservatives
once understood
place matters
architecture matters frankly it matters
a lot more than tax rates
roger scrutin the late conservative
philosopher one of the more important
conservative philosophers of our age he
just died a few years ago
scrutin said if you want to conserve
a place if you want to conserve a
country if you want people
to be more conservative they need to
like where they live it needs to be
beautiful
every place that you are in is either
going to slightly elevate your spirits
or lower your spirits the one of the
best things that donald trump did as
president not that it's going to have
much of an effect probably is that he
signed an executive order called make
our federal buildings beautiful again
because you know you walk through
washington dc on the one hand you see
this beautiful neoclassical
architecture and you think this is big
this is beautiful this is inspiring this
lifts my eyes up you look at the supreme
court
it's a it's a beautiful building that
raises you up that that makes you stand
a little straighter that makes you feel
a little bit more dignified and then you
look at i don't know the
african-american history museum or the
native american history museum or any of
these modern buildings that are ugly or
even
beyond those sort of monument type
things on the mall you look at just the
the office buildings from that were
built in the 60s 70s up until the
present and they're soulless and they're
ugly and they're brutal and they lower
your spirits it's like the difference
between you coming to new york but they
actually just fixed up penn station it's
a lot nicer now but before they did that
you come into new york and you go into
grand central and you that's on the east
side you walk in to the grand central
train station and you feel big you feel
like you're in the city you feel like
you're you're if you can make it here
you can make it anywhere you come into
madison square garden right you're
underneath madison square garden and the
penn station that they that they had
after they knocked down the beautiful
old one you feel like a rat running
through a maze you don't feel dignified
you feel dirty you feel low you feel
small
this is a really important point i hope
conservatives get it edmund burke who
was the considered the father of modern
conservative thought he was an aesthetic
philosopher
he was he was a man who thought about
what beauty does to us there is a line
charlie's lying then i'll get off this
point but it really struck me it's so
true
it was almost chestertonian
gk chesterton the great great uh writer
conservative christian writer he
made this point in one of his detective
stories about uh father brown he had
this detective series the father brown
series
and he puts in the words of in the mouth
of father brown this statement
i think there's something rather
dangerous about standing on these high
places even to pray
heights were made to be looked at not to
be looked from look at that blacksmith
for instance a good man but not a
christian hard imperious unforgiving
well his scotch religion was made up by
men who prayed on hills and high crags
and learnt to look down on the world
more than to look up to heaven humility
is the mother of giants one sees great
things from the valley only small things
from the peak i knew a man who began by
worshiping with others before the altar
but who grew fond of high and lonely
places to pray from corners or niches in
the belfry or the spire
and once in one of those dizzy places
where the whole world seemed to turn
under him like a wheel his brain turned
also and he fancied he was god he
thought it was given to him to judge the
world and strike down the sinner he
would never have had such a thought if
he had been kneeling with other men upon
a floor but he saw all men walking about
like insects he saw one especially
strutting just below him insolent and
evident by a bright green hat a
poisonous
insect
perfectly sums up
that those two views of the world when
you're up in that high rise in new york
you look down the world is so small all
those little people they look like ants
but when you're down on the ground on
your knees looking up into the sky into
the mountains
you feel your own play you feel that you
are small you have a little bit of
humility and you see the greatness and
beauty
of the world
so all of that to say charlie's right
let's build more beautiful buildings and
stop building soulless high-rises in the
cities that are turning all of our
countrymen into big libs you know what's
not turning our countrymen into big libs
cnn because nobody's watching it there
are new numbers out from cnn plus cnn
plus is cnn's version of the daily wire
cnn is this old cable company
they've been a very prominent force in
cable for decades now and then they look
at our company the daily wire which has
exploded as a digital streaming service
and they say okay we want to do that so
they start a product called cnn plus
it's a subscription digital streaming
service and they hire chris wallace this
big name he's been in journalism forever
his father was a huge name in journalism
they hire him away from fox news he's
going to be the big anchor on the cnn
plus platform how many people do you
think are using cnn plus
according to a report that just came out
from cnbc
fewer than 10 000 daily users
think about right now
just on this one show
when you think of all the platforms that
we're on just on this one show here
we have hundreds of thousands
of listeners and viewers
just here just just one show how many
shows do we have how many different
people are engaging with the different
shows every day just the subscriber base
just the subscribers alone to daily
wired six hundred thousand
we started in a pool house seven years
ago cnn is supposed to be the biggest
name in news
cnn can't muster 10 000
daily listeners chris wallace is
apparently blowing his casket over this
there's a report that just came out
that chris wallace
uh is uh having daily breakdowns this is
from the reporter john nicosia
over the miserable launch of cnn plus he
says he wants a tv show where he's going
to walk it's just he can't get over how
terrible the launch has been
i know why the launch is so terrible
because for the first time in a long
time cnn is open to the market
for a long time cnn has not really had
to be accountable to market forces
because cnn gets bundled up in cable
it's got a long legacy name and because
they put it on in airports
people don't sit down on their couch and
watch cnn people walk by cnn when
they're going from terminal to terminal
in the airport but it doesn't matter
because the cable companies aren't going
to remove it because it's all bundled up
together and it doesn't matter what
viewers want now cnn is offering a
service that actually requires them to
provide value for their customers and
it's failing because they don't provide
value to their customers because the
only way the libs are able to push their
nonsense is by forcing it down our
throats at gunpoint and when they don't
do that
it's not it doesn't work
which is why the libs are clamping up
before november because they know gosh
the this stuff ain't selling this is
what we are offering is not playing in
peoria so we've got we got a lock down
again we got to extend the mass mandate
we got to push the mail in ballots we
got to do whatever we can to be to avoid
being answerable to the voters look at
kamala harris's job approval rating
so kamala harris is job approval ready i
misspoke
i misspoke earlier when i was talking to
jen
i said that kamala's job approval rating
is 35
that's true but only in one specific
context kamala's approval rating is
actually in the 20s
nationally
the 35 percent number comes from
california
kambala's state that she represented in
the u.s senate where she was the
attorney general
kamala's approval rating is 35 in one of
the bluest states
in america that's not according to some
right-wing poll that's according to the
berkeley institute of government studies
berkeley it's the most left-wing place
in on of any campus just about
35 approval for kamala 45
disapprove
so what are they going to do they've got
to bring back covid
kovitt is going to help them covet is
going to help them on oil prices very
possibly and more importantly covet's
going to help them at the ballot box so
they've got to bring it
back
what they are selling people just know
is not true there there is a news story
i'll leave you on this note today
there's a news story out of metro
headline is
prepare you pull over if you're driving
sit down headline is
ex-soldier exposed her penis and used
wheelie bin as sex toy in public
there it is i'm not making that up
the x the story
is tabloid fodder enough
but
then there's a scandal on top of the
scandal that the tabloid is using her to
refer to him i think it's pretty clear
that it's him ex-soldier is using her
penis is she is she now
is that the case for her no and people
just know
it's bonkers this is how i feel about
squishy republicans i'm all for building
coalitions and i get it a lot of people
are to the left of me but we can maybe
still form coalitions
the transgender thing is
is a line in the sand for me
if you've got a spencer cox or an asa
hutchinson or these squish republican
governors who who cave on the
transgender issue spencer cox now using
preferred pronouns
you're out of my party you're out i
don't be and i think this is true for a
lot of voters not even just republicans
but normal democrats normal people in
the middle they say no if you're gonna
whatever political view has led us to
the point that we're referring to her
penis what whatever it is i don't know
what your your views on immigration and
crime and taxes i don't know whatever
led us to this moment i'm against it my
political ideology is whatever
prevents us from using the pronoun her
with
male anatomical features okay because we
just know it you don't need a phd in
political philosophy to know that that
is completely wrong and the voters know
it about what the biden administration
is selling it's why they don't
have a lot of support right now in that
administration and it's why they're
trying to clamp down on our rights to
express our views because it's the only
way they're going to hold on to any
power i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show